kein mensch verlässt sein land lässt
alles zurück begibt sich auf einen weg
wie hier said schildert bringt sein
leben in gefahr wenn dieser mensch
keinen richtig guten grund dafür hätte
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen ich straße direkt
mit der ersten frage von 13 fragen mit
der konflikt frage muss die eu mehr
migration zu lassen um die krise an den
außengrenzen zu beenden wenn ihr sagt ja
sie muss auf jeden fall mehr migration
zu lassen dann geht er aufs feld
wenn ihr sagt nein das ist einfach der
falsche weg dann geht er aufs gelbe fed
[Musik]
ok alles klar jetzt wissen wir wo ihr
steht noch immer versuchen menschen
täglich die grenzen zu europa zu
überwinden um schutz zu suchen oder ein
besseres leben führen zu können
dabei ertranken tausende von ihnen
mittelmeer und die die überleben landen
oft in katastrophalen lagern die bilder
der zustände an den eu-außengrenzen
könnten kaum alarmieren da sein und
trotzdem fehlen bis heute gemeinsame
asylsystem und menschenrechtsstandards
der mitgliedstaaten die die lage
verbessern können was muss also jetzt
passieren muss die eu mehr migration zu
lassen um die krise an den außengrenzen
zu beenden bei 310 fragen sind sich
meine gäste erst mal uneinig umso
spannender deswegen werden sie sich am
ende der folge zusammenraufen können und
ein kompromiss oder sogar eine lösung
finden ab jetzt gilt es wenn ihr der
anderen seite zustimmen wollt dann könnt
ihr einen schritt auf sie zugehen
und wenn euch vielleicht etwas aufregt
sauer macht ärgert was auch immer und
ihr euch das kurz im kopf vormerken
wollt dann könnt ihr schon mal einen
schritt zurückgehen und mein ziel ist es
natürlich am ende hier im kompromiss
feld zu vereinen klick direkt los mit
meiner zweiten frage von 13 fragen an
dich sehen geht die nämlich du bist 2013
aus dem sudan über libyen über das
mittelmeer nach deutschland geflohen
du lebst seit 2005 10 und deutschland
und hat auch ein buch über deine flucht
erfahrungen geschrieben
maximal kurz deine persönliche
geschichte mit uns teilen
vielen dank bis 13 von süden über
ägypten libyen ist nach deutschland
angekommen ist dann bin ich an
ich habe in libyen 19 monaten gelebt und
ich konnte das nicht vorstellen was das
wirklich es in libyen kann man einfach
die waffen kaufen genauso wie gemüse und
dann willkommen und schießen uns also
liebe ja war kein sicheres ordnen sich
aus platz bei uns und für mich selber
gar nix leider das traurig ist dass die
leute auf falsches bild haben und
migranten migration und dass die leute
her gekommen sind oder hier gekommen
sind dass die einfach ihrem leben retten
und wir wollen einfach etwas gutes
machen und ich hoffe dass und ich
wünsche mir dass die leute uns bestehen
dass das warum wir hier sind wenn man in
libyen ist man hat nur ein tanz dann
wieder entdecken oder sich gesetzt
worden also mit 1 prozent an und das ist
dass nach europa gekommen
du sagst also es gab für dich kein
ausweg du musstest du weg hat sich dann
auf den weg nach europa gemacht
wie lief das ab was war dein nein das
ist das noch schlimmer weil mir das war
noch schlimmer das ist und dass wir
nicht so erzähle dass ich glaube das
dauert richtig lang also ich habe ganz
viele gründe die das dann ich konnte
nicht nach so dann wieder zurückgehen
ich wollte nur einfach einen einem land
nicht sicher fühlen dann bin ich einfach
sondern weil ich ein student war und ich
war gegen die regierung von sodann ich
musste einfach auf jeden fall sollen sie
dann weg nachdem ist nach ägypten
gefahren bin also gereist bin habe ich
mich gefühlt dass in ägypten mit einem
anruf konnte sie noch so dann wäre das
zurückgehen weil da der ägyptischen
präsidenten zusammenarbeiten
und dann musste ich einfach weiter aber
ich wusste nicht wohin und wie bin ich
nach libyen gekommen
jeden tag etwas neues passiert
eigentlich wenn wir verlieren kumpels
freuen davon und die mit uns immer reden
und so weist und einfach die anderen
seiten oder die liebe gekommen und
schießen uns und machen alles was wir
wollen und keine reagieren dass und kein
jemanden berichten dass es gibt keine
presse wird niemand der damals in libyen
ist 2013 bis 2014 alles ist da war was
berichtet jeden tag passiert hier einen
rumba morgen wurde jemand getötet man
merkt also wenn du deine geschichte
erzählt du bist von einem unglück reicht
eigentlich nicht als wort aber ich nenne
das jetzt mal unglück ins nächste von
einem land ins nächste
die leute die die im mittel möchte haben
die sind mit ganz viel
gesagt ein tagen bevor ich in diesem
boot mit 651 leute menschen darüber nach
italien kam
da ein ganzes schiff fast 400 leute da
gestorben
und deswegen so dafür dass die eu mehr
migration zulässt könnt ihr das
verstehen also ich habe sehr sehr viele
menschen getroffen die geschichten
hatten wie seine und ich glaube dass wir
hier wahrscheinlich alle der gleichen
meinung sind dass das was derzeit
passiert und was seit einigen jahren
passiert inakzeptabel ist zum einen ist
das mittelmeer die tödlichste grenze der
welt und das betrifft und sollte jeden
europäer oder jeder ob er in betroffen
machen
zum anderen ist dieses thema die angst
vor einer angeblichen massenmigration
sprengstoff in den händen von populisten
die damit nicht nur die
flüchtlingskonvention sondern den
gesamten menschenrechtsschutz und die
rechtsstaatlichkeit in der eu aushebeln
und in die luft jagen wollen
es gilt hier humane lösungen
humane grenzen kontrolle und empathie
zusammenzubringen
gelingt uns das nicht dann verliert
europa hier seine seele wir müssen
verhindern dass so viele menschen
ertrinken
wir hatten 800 tote in diesem jahr im
zentralen mittelmeer allein die frage
ist also wie machen wir das
das ist die entscheidende frage wir
müssen diese frage trennen von der frage
wie lösen wir die humanitäre krise
mittelmeer wie helfen wir flüchtlingen
und es geht ihr um eine flucht
geschichte aus davor aus einem gebiet
eines landes in afrika wo der
internationale strafgerichtshof
ermittelt wie helfen wir dass menschen
wie du nicht in nach libyen gelockt
werden nicht erst nach wien kommen
müssen nicht in libyen verschärft werden
und nicht dann russisches roulette mit
ihrem leben spielen in diesen boten also
die frage ist was machen wir
und ich glaube wir müssen trennen die
zahl um die es hier heute geht die zahl
von flüchtlingen die auf diesem weg
heute nach europa kommen ist sehr sehr
klein und die zahl von legalen wegen ist
noch kleiner es gibt keine legalen wege
es gibt kein resettlement aus afrika das
wollen julia von europa ehrlich gesagt
weil ich bin auch nicht davor dass die
leute aber das müssen wir kommen ich
habe gemacht aber ich würde niemanden
empfehlen das über das mittelmeer zu
kommen aber ich hoffe und ich wünsche
von europa dass das die leute helfen
katar ich würde gern zu dir kommt der
arbeitet seit 30 jahren ehrenamtlich in
der geflüchteten hilfe erlebt hautnah
auch wie es ist mit denen oder wie sie
menschen auch er geht dies nach europa
ich sag jetzt mal sozusagen geschafft
haben
was sind denn deine erfahrung mit der
europäischen flüchtlingspolitik wenn es
darum geht menschen mit dem
notwendigsten zu versorgen lebensmittel
dach über dem kopf medizinische
grundversorgung schaffen wir noch 20
millionen das ist kein problem diese
leute die hierher kommen die haben alle
solche geschichten es kommt keiner hier
her einfach nur weil er denkt ach jetzt
gehst du mal nach deutschland da ist es
so toll
die lassen ihre familien zurück die
verscherbeln zu hause das letzte haben
gut der familie um irgendwelche
schlepper und schleuser zu bezahlen
bekommen die tollsten stories erzählt
und kommen dann hier her und sind
erstmal völlig schockiert und wenn ich
sehe dass ich jetzt noch
spötter behaupten 80 der flüchtlinge die
2015 gekommen sind in den
gemeinschaftsunterkünften sitzen habe
allen abgelehnten asylantrag alle in
widerspruch gegangen
alle von abschiebung bedroht ich kann
gar nicht so viele psychologen termine
wahrnehmen
ja wie ich muss weil ich jeden tag angst
habe dass mir irgendeine aus dem fenster
springt also es kann niemals die lösung
sein zu sagen wir nehmen jetzt alle
flüchtlinge auf deutschland ist ein
sozialstaat und ein sozialstaat der von
jedem unterwandert werden kann der wird
nicht lange bestand haben diese alle
europäischen länder in der verantwortung
aber wir zahlen das pferd von hinten rum
auf die lösung ist es nicht dass wir
immer mehr menschen hierher holen und
wir sind eigentlich gar nichts mit ihnen
anzufangen
divine outsourced in irgendwelche dörfer
käfer weil der freie wohnungen sind da
in text über die menschen nett ich bin
ja auch deutsch lernen für flüchtlinge
und können sagen nach sechs jahren
wenn ich jetzt mal prozentual
runterbrechen müsste sind 70 prozent mit
denen ich immer hält mich noch auf
englisch oder arabisch unterhalten und
ich habe wirklich eintrat als ich bin
selber muslimen ja mein lebenszeit ist
kurdischer türkischer umfeldes
multikulturell
aber es ist echt schwer ja ich denke
einfach wir sind in der verantwortung
aber wir müssen doch mal helfen die
fluchtursachen zu beseitigen aber dann
noch einmal zum verständnis du bist also
dafür dass wir nicht mehr also dass die
eu sich nicht mehr migration zu lassen
dafür dass wir erst mal die leute hier
gescheit integrieren und in die mitte
der gesellschaft zu machen wir
erfolgreich sind 2016 2017
ich meine auch letztes jahr waren es ja
jetzt wieder über 100000 wobei es waren
über 25.000 kinder die hier geboren
wurden
über die reden wir auch nicht sehen man
euch schon positioniert ihr seid bei der
ein schritt zurück gegangen sein warum
weil selbst gesagt erst einmal die leute
die hierher kommen sind aber es gibt
leute die im nord noch die sind noch im
nord die sinnliche note die hier sind
also ich bin nicht ich habe mein eigenes
auto ich auch meinen eigenen stoppte
aber das ist nicht die masse
ich kann dir zu tun als ob das jetzt die
messe wäre es ist nicht so und genau
diese situation muss man vergleichen mit
der situation der geflüchteten in ihren
herkunftsländern oder auf der
fluchtroute oder an den europäischen
außen
letztlich muss wenn man das mal client
unterstand ist einfach ein unterschied
die eu muss auf jeden fall mehr
migration zu lassen was die aktuelle
abschottungspolitik europas bedeutet ist
sich das in diesem moment menschen im
mittelmeer ertrinken nach libyen in
folterlager verschleppt werden oder auf
den griechischen inseln in jenes lagern
verrotten
das ist die europäische
abschottungspolitik und dafür gibt es
keinen grund den menschen wissen wissen
sie wie es denen geht die habe ich da
sitzen die holen sich die augen aus die
mutter sitzt in syrien hat krebs die
könnte man mehr über die mutter stirbt
der kanzlei eignen bayer deckung nicht
nur das heißt ein asylantrag nicht was
sie eigentlich wollen wir uns duzen oder
siezen
was du ja eigentlich beschreibst ist die
diskriminierende und rassistische
politik die in deutschland gemacht wird
die in europa gemacht wird um mit
geflüchteten umzugehen also ich glaube
die themen rassismus und einwanderung
spielen in meiner musik deswegen eine
große rolle weil ich eine persönliche
vorgeschichte eine familiengeschichte
habe in der das eine rolle spielt und
weil ich es nicht ertragen kann mit
anzusehen wie menschenrechte und
generell menschen leben so mit füßen
getreten werden jetzt zu sagen wir
behandeln hier schon so scheiße und
können den nicht ordentlich helfen weil
wir zu wenig geld in die hand nehmen zu
wenig personal schaffen zu wenig bildung
schaffen
also müssen wir die leute dort verrecken
lassen wo es ihnen schlecht geht etwa
die leute zu bilden die schon ewig hier
sind ich war vorher zehn jahre
arbeitslosen in den ersten arbeitsmarkt
integriert mit vermittlungshemmnissen
nicht mal das haben wir geschafft also
ist die konsequenz wenn man muss leute
diese erkenntnisse haben ist ja noch
schwieriger aber ich nicht ein dass das
problem was du beschreibt das 17 junge
afrikanische männer seit jahren
abgelehnt ohne zukunft aber das problem
sagt das problem ist ja dass in deinem
fall wir reden von einem anerkannten
flüchtlingen und die syrer waren
anerkannte flüchtlinge brauchten nicht
so lustig habe auch die option bekommen
ich war auch nicht einhält kann ich habe
noch weiter gekämpft ich habe
weitergemacht ja und das war auch mein
aussehen wurde abgelehnt ich glaube
ihnen fast abgeschoben
während der ausbildung die frage
ist doch haben wir nicht zwei probleme
wo wir eigentlich zusammenkommen
wir wollen nicht dass sich menschen auf
den weg machen die eigentlich in ihren
ländern keinen sicher weniger lesen sind
keine flüchtlinge also das wissen wir
und ich weiß ja egal ich habe dann hat
er gesprochen
leute aus eritrea sind flüchtlinge für
die müssen wir einen weg finden legal zu
kommen oder legal in nachbarländern
schutz zu bekommen weil es werden nicht
alle kommen können aber für andere haben
wir jetzt ein spezielles problem die
sind jetzt hier und wenn wir jetzt den
fehler machen als gesellschaft zu sagen
wir lassen uns in diesem
flüchtlingsheimen wir erwarten dass das
irgendwie verschwinden das werden die
nicht gern da bleiben also eigentlich
leiden da deal eigentlich müssen wir
ehrlich sein und sagen wir machen eine
liberalisierung wir geben denen die
nicht verurteilt wurden für straftaten
nicht eine chance zu bleiben
wir müssen heute davon abhalten er
keinen schutz brauchen sich auf den weg
zu machen aber die die hier sehen müssen
integrieren eine legalisierung eine
chance zu bleiben was sagst du dazu mal
war ich glaube dass wir auf jeden fall
einer legalisierung brauchen ich glaube
auch auf jeden fall dass wir sichere
produkte nach europa brauchen ich glaube
das kein weg an rettung vorbeiführt und
ich gebe auch die recht die situation
der aufnahme in deutschland aktuell ist
katastrophal und viele geflüchtete
leiden auch hier das hallo ich zustimme
wo ich jeweils nicht zustimme ist dass
ich glaube bei das ist eine schatten
debatte die eigentlich vom aktuellen
problemen ablenkt wenn wir das in der
konsequenz weiter denken würden was
bedeutet dass zusagen momentan haben wir
schon so viele probleme hier alle
anderen die jetzt an den europäischen
grenzen warten oder ertrinken oder
verrotten für die haben wir leider keine
lösung die müssen noch weitere doch im
jahre warten oder die süße kleine gehört
haben sie sich verlagern seite auch das
kann das kann ja keiner kommissionen
greifen ihre familie verlassen damit sie
sich erleben können es ist doch in
unserer verantwortung dort solche
zustände zu schaffen dass die menschen
eben nicht mehr solche wege auf sich
nehmen müssen aber es ist einfach so es
ist nicht immer damit getan die wollte
sie holen würde ich gern noch mal fragen
weil du hast dich noch gar nicht bewegt
warum hat sich noch kein argument bisher
überzeugt da waren sehr viele
interessante argumente denen ich auch
zustimmen kann aber ohne das jetzt so
wahnsinnig viel bewegung notwendig
gewesen wäre
ich glaube insgesamt ist
eine hochkomplexe fragen es gibt nicht
die eine homogene antwort darauf die
begrenzung von migration ist wichtig um
die akzeptanz in der bevölkerung zu
erhalten der einen seite auf der anderen
seite um auch den menschen die zu uns
kommen überhaupt lebensperspektiven zu
bieten und ich finde es wichtig ist
wirklich weil wir ein bisschen europa
sehr stark vermischt migration und
flucht asyl dass wir das wieder stärker
trennen
auch für migranten aus drittstaaten
sichere wege schaffen aber da ganz klar
auch sagen hier müssen bestimmte
voraussetzungen auch der arbeitsmarkt
integration vorab erfüllt sein
während wenn jemand natürlich schutz
braucht dass kein relevanter aspekt ist
da können wir nachher natürlich daran
arbeiten hoffen dass die menschen in den
arbeitsmarkt reinkommen wir dürfen es
aber natürlich nicht davon abhängig
machen
an der würde ich gerne kunden ein haken
ich finde es fatal da so einen menschen
rechtliches ranking aufzumachen zwischen
migrantinnen die es verdient haben zu
kommen und andere die zurück in den tod
geschickt werden
ich glaube dass diese unterscheidung in
keiner hinsicht gerechtfertigt als die
andere sache ist das erstmal jeder ganz
unabhängig von dem fluchtgrund ein recht
hat zu kommen es gibt ein recht zu
kommen und es gibt ein recht auf ein
faires individuelles asylverfahren es
gibt es gibt kein recht auf migration
also zu sagen es würde ich kenne dann
bewegung sehr stark normalisierten
diskurs zu sagen es muss ein
menschenrecht auf migration geben nur
letztendlich wenn wir das in konkrete
politik übersetzen funktioniert das ja
nicht weil das ja dann bedeuten wird es
sind unglaubliche zahlen auch sehr
reiche länder da können sie die
golfstaaten mit reichen da können sich
china mit 9 1 gegen alle dann ein
menschenrecht auf migration in die
wenigen liberaldemokratische fasten
staaten der welt das würde nicht
funktionieren
das würde uns ganz klar überlassen das
heißt wir müssen um auch zu
gewährleisten dass die aufnahme
gesellschaften weiterhin bereit sind das
ist ja zentral weiterhin bereits in
menschen aufzunehmen ihnen signalisieren
können wir nehmen wirklich die menschen
auf die den schutz brauchen und nicht
jeder der nach europa möchte braucht in
schutz
erst an du bist musiker und du sammelst
immer wieder auf den konzerten geld für
die seenotrettung was ist dein
persönlicher grund dafür hast du da auch
eine persönliche verbundenheit oder
verpflichtungen die du fühlst zu helfen
ich muss mich schon damit anfreunden
dass leute sich auf
diese seite des feldes stellen ich finde
es noch schlimmer das seit jetzt sieben
jahren ungefähr auf kosten von
menschenleben auf kosten von schicksalen
politik gemacht wird währenddessen ja
passieren geschichten wie seine dich
unvorstellbar finde und irgendwie also
ich kann mich nicht in einen menschen
hineinversetzen der sich das alles
angucken und nichts tun will
was denkt ihr denn dazu seid ihr
grundsätzlich für mehr bewegungsfreiheit
und demnach auch grenzen die so offen
wie möglich sind schreibt es gern mal in
die kommentare
bauer ich habe es vorhin schon erwähnt
ist fehlen bis heute gemeinsame
asylsysteme und menschenrechts standards
der eu warum waren sechs jahre nicht
genug zeit ehrlich gesagt die genau
gleiche frage stelle ich mir auch warum
und das hat hätte ich das auch fatal
dass wir hier auf diesem spielfeld
weiter verhandeln weil das ist im grunde
die situation die wir seit jahren in der
eu haben eine so genannte
verhandlungssituation und da fragt man
sich schon über was wird hier eigentlich
verhandelt wird über menschenrechte und
über menschenleben verhandelt und die
verantwortung wird sich immer
gegenseitig zu pushen
in italien geht es nicht darum können
wir jetzt nichts machen wir müssen
erstmal hier die situation lösen
davor können wir auch nicht die menschen
an den außengrenzen retten und ich
glaube diese situation ist unhaltbar
es muss jetzt ein land vorgehen mit
anderen switch in der vergangenheit ich
bin doch eigentlich schönen begriff die
koalition der willigen genannt es kann
nicht sein dass einzelne rechtsextrem
regierte rassistische länder die gesamte
migrationspolitik in der eu seit jahren
blockieren
und das hat brauchen wir jetzt länder
menschen bewegungen die verantwortung
über bedingt da glaube ich die koalition
der willigen maximal klären koalition
der willigen ist die idee dass es nicht
mehr alle mitgliedstaaten in der eu
gemeinsam entscheiden müssen was
passiert mit den geflüchteten an den
außengrenzen sondern dass die länder die
durchaus bereit sind und das ist die
mehrheit mehr geflüchtete mehr migrant
und dann bei sich aufzunehmen und auch
die kapazitäten dafür haben und das
mehrfach signalisiert haben es sind in
ganz europa mittlerweile über 600
kommunen allein in deutschland sind es
über 252 die sagen wir
die möglichkeit haben die plätze wir
haben den bildern die leute aufzunehmen
gerade bis zwei schritte auf maria zuge
kommen warum weil genau das die antwort
sein muss und ich genau wie du überzeugt
bin
dafür gebe es in einigen europäischen
ländern auch mehrheiten
ich hatte viele gespräche mit politikern
in den letzten wochen und das
interessante ist war auch mitglied einer
fluchtursachen kommission die die
bundesregierung eingerichtet hat aber
eine csu politikerinnen eine
spd-politikerin die vorsitzenden und die
hat empfohlen 40.000 resettlement plätze
acht mal mehr als deutschland jetzt auf
nimmt jedes jahr um echte flüchtlinge
die mit dem hci oder auch durch
gemeinden durch bürger durch städte wie
in kanada genannt werden dass die auf
legalem weg kommen können also die frage
warum wir hier stehen ist sollte die eu
mehr migration zu lassen und nicht
beginnen wir mit geflüchteten um also
ich verstehe nicht an welchem punkt der
differenzierung schaffen willst wer not
sucht oder hilfe von links kommentieren
okay die gelten jetzt aber wir wissen
jetzt schon dass in den nächsten jahren
die ursachen nicht nur kriege sein
werden sondern es werden dürren dazu
kommen es werden naturkatastrophen dazu
kommen die klimakatastrophe wird
passieren ob wir wollen oder nicht
und das werden fluchtursachen sein wo
wenn man hier mit 250.000 menschen in
einem kontinent wo mehrere hundert
millionen leben
er kommt man nicht weit und das ist auch
nicht zukunftsgewandt ich schließe
michael greis vorschlag an
aber so war eine interessante frage drin
die du hast ihn aufgeworfen hast du
sagst gut 250.000 kann man sagen ist
nicht so viel über seine tal kommen ja
auch sprechen
aber was wäre denn dann die zahl also
gibt es nicht für dich irgendwann auch
ein punkt wo du sagst wir haben
samariter dilemma ja das ist ja also es
gibt immer mehr not auf der welt als der
hilfsbereite letztendlich befriedigen
kann also wo würdest du denn sagen ist
dann für dich irgendwo in puncto auch
europa sagen müsste jetzt könnten wir
nicht weiter aufnehmen darüber müssen
wir dann schwerpunkt ist meiner meinung
nach wir sind nicht dieser marita
sondern wir sind die urheber des ganzen
wir leben auf der privilegierten seite
der welt die dafür verantwortlich ist
dass die unterprivilegierte seite der
welt
immer mehr probleme bekommt und solange
das so ist so lange eine politik gemacht
wird weltweit die auf kosten der ärmeren
auf kurs der unterprivilegierten geht so
lange wird sich daran auch nichts ändern
und dann sind wir in der pflicht wir
sind nicht dieser marita die die hand
aufhalten sondern wir sind in der
pflicht den menschen zu helfen die vor
diesen von uns verschuldeten missständen
oder mitverschuldeten missständen
fliehen so arbeit ist keine antwort auf
meine frage weil es war eine ganz
konkrete frage die um zahlen ging und b
ist es die welt ist nicht so
unterkomplex das alles nur davon
bestimmt wird was wir machen und das in
den ländern überhaupt kein handel
stattfinden würde
der größte teil der konflikte und der
probleme die ihn stehen entstehen
aufgrund von korrupten und
ausbeuterischen eliten deshalb geht es
in vielen ländern nicht voran
das hat eben nicht mehr ursächlich mit
europa zu tun europa könnte einiges
besser machen das sehe ich auch so
und da sollten wir auch ran aber zu
sagen alles ist nur unsere schuld heißt
im grunde die sind ja überhaupt nicht
handlungsfähig die leute dort natürlich
sind die jungs werden das habe ich aber
im umkehrschluss heißt das dass ich
hätte jetzt trotzdem gerne antwort auf
die frage wo siehst du denn dann die
grenze für mich gibt es keine grenze das
auto zwei milliarden 3 milliarden 4
milliarden
weil die welt sich so entwickelt dass
diese menschen von dort weg müssen diese
unterscheidung in sogenannte waren
flüchtlinge und nicht wahre flüchtlinge
die entspricht nicht der realität kein
mensch verlässt sein land lässt alles
zurück begibt sich auf einen weg bin
hier wayne schildert bringt sein leben
in die farben dieser mensch keinen
richtig guten grund dafür hätte
darunter sollte allerdings konvention
nicht weit genug greift nicht mehr alle
fluchtursachen abdecken kann und wie
eine neue vision brauchen und die sollte
sich orientieren an dem menschenrecht
bewegungsfreiheit haltung wird einen
schritt auf sie zurück lebt da bin ich
dass das ist eine these die ich auch
immer vertrete ich kann es nicht mehr
hören
zwischen richtiger flüchtlinge und nicht
richtiger flüchtlingen und was weiß ich
wie sie gesagt hat da sind wir zu 100
prozent beieinander
natürlich sind die gründe
unterschiedlich die einfliegen vor krieg
die anderen fliegen vor armut und ich
finde das ist auch legitim vor armut
zufrieden und ich finde das völlig
legitim wenn diese leute sind
weg machen und sagen sie möchten einfach
für sich und ihre familie ein besseres
leben
das würde ich genauso machen das würden
wir glaube ich alle genauso machen
ich sehe ja eine kleine einigung ihr
seid alle ein schritt auf katja
zugegangen gerät muss deutschland eine
vorreiterrolle übernehmen
ja ist die kurze antwort die etwas
längere antwort ist deutschland
übernimmt diese vorreiterrolle seit
vielen jahren zum glück kein land der
welt hat so viele flüchtlinge mit einer
positiven asyl entscheidung ausgestattet
wie deutschland ist die größte
asylbehörde der welt eine million
menschen haben hier schutz bekommen
in italien waren 120 1000 weil in
italien die leute zwar ankommen aber
nicht geblieben sind sind weitergezogen
also bedeutet das für dich die
vorreiterrolle in deutschland ist schon
komplett ausgereift sein nein ich glaube
was wir jetzt brauchen ist deutschland
mit vorschlägen die andere überzeugen
ohne die es nicht geht wir müssen dieser
linie überzeugen um die seenotrettung
wiederherzustellen staatliche
seenotrettung zentralen mittelmeer geht
nur mit italien
und wenn die tage in seiner häfen
schließt wenn radio saline in einem jahr
premierminister ist oder in zweien dann
hat deutschland ein problem wir müssen
also die italiener überzeugen mit einem
konzept wir retten rettung allein genügt
nicht wir müssen leute holen die schutz
brauchen wir brauchen aber auch partner
und wir müssen auch leute zurückschicken
die keinen schutz brauchen da würde mich
nach meinung interessiert sollte
deutschland in der eu flüchtlingspolitik
eine vorreiterrolle übernehmen
ich habe jetzt einen kompromissvorschlag
und danach könnt ihr noch gemeinsam auf
jedem feld die köpfe zusammenstecken und
euch ein kompromissvorschlag überlegen
den jahren die andere seite richtet aber
erst mal fangen wir mit einem
kompromissvorschlag an der innerhalb der
eu noch kein konsens über
menschenrechtsstandards herrscht müssen
wir auf dem weg zu einem einheitlichen
europäischen vorgehen andere lösungen
finden die das leid an den außengrenzen
schnellstmöglich beenden
okay ihr seid alle ein schritt auf mich
zugegangen
dann könnt ihr euch jetzt jeweils in
jedem fällt quasi ein
kompromissvorschlag überlegen ob mehr
migration zugelassen werden soll oder
nicht weil wie andere gefahr ist was ich
gehört hab ich habe diesen vorschlag
gemacht weil es einfach es geht kein
futter ziel
das war bisher eine ganz schön hitzige
diskussion ich hoffe dass wir gleich
noch ein paar kompromisse finden können
habt ihr denn noch 1 30 40.000 halbjahr
das ist also das muss mehr migration
zugelassen werden sonst werden sich
diese probleme nicht lösen
das bist du das war stark weil ich
grünes feld was habt ihr euch überlegt
wir haben heute kein kompromiss im
angebot bei menschenrechten und bei
menschen neben darf es keinen kompromiss
geben
menschenrechte müssen unverhandelbar
sein und bleiben und das möchten wir an
dieser stelle gerne signalisieren
deshalb kein komponist von unserer seite
na gut man kann natürlich sagen
menschenrechte unverhandelbar aber das
ist fast das ist eine religiöse doktrin
ich muss alles in konkrete politik
umsetzen können und da gibt es natürlich
auch bei uns bei den grundrechten in
deutschland gibt es ja immer wieder
abwägungsprozesses kollidieren der
grundrechte gibt und ich hatten
demokratisches prinzip also ich muss
natürlich auch im zuge der politischen
willensbildung mehrheiten organisieren
es gibt natürlich die grundrechte aber
das absolute grundrecht dafür dass jedes
würde das bedeuten dass jeder auf der
welt in rechts hat nach deutschland zu
kommen das kann es nicht geben das kann
eben auch in praktische politik nicht
übersetzt werden
das machte so unglaublich das macht es
aber so unglaublich schwierig mehr hat
dieses ganz hohe menschenrecht was aber
als konkrete politik in der form bisher
gedacht wird mit auf die zehn milliarden
ball zu gehen eine menschheit niemals
umsetzbar ist das heißt wir müssen alles
selbst machen dann müsste man ja dass
menschenrechte anpassen es gibt kein
menschenrecht auf migration
es gibt es einfach ein menschenrecht auf
bewegungsfreiheit der ausreise aber
nicht der einreise das ist der große
unterschied im völkerrecht gibt es das
recht auf ausreise aus einem staat aber
nicht dass ich irgendwo überhaupt
einreisen konnten das häutchen dann
bleiben
und ja es stimmt es darf nicht einfach
nur bei grundsatzpositionen bleiben
sondern man braucht konkrete vorschläge
wie man damit umgehen kann und die haben
wir die liefern wir seit jahren die
einzigen die blockieren sind nach wie
vor die politik dann höre ich mir gerne
wir hören uns gerne euren
kompromissvorschlag anja wir haben uns
jetzt was ganz konkretes noch von dem
von ihr eingebrachten
kompromissvorschlag überlegt diese
situation dass man lange diese
unsicherheit hat und nicht wirklich
planen kann und dass deprimierend für
die menschen ist diese zu beenden und so
sagen wer jetzt eben aus diesen ländern
da ist zwar kein asyl zugesprochen
bekommen hat oder keine schutzstatus der
darf aber bleiben aber gleichzeitig klar
zu kommunizieren für alle die jetzt neu
hinzu kommen gilt es dann
nicht mehr verständnis frage das heißt
nachdem man das jetzt einmal großzügig
samariter mies gemacht hat ist man
danach strikt und verhinderten migration
in die eu
dass man macht sich vielleicht erst mal
gedanken wie man sie finanziert wie man
die leute menschenwürdig und es dahin
verhinderten und in einer nicht für sich
in den play wir wollen nicht wohin wir
wollen wir nur sagen unser ziel ist klar
zu signalisieren die die jetzt da sind
die viele jahre da sind die genau das
was du geschrieben hast die auch die
akzeptanz in der bevölkerung reduzieren
weil ich sagen das ist doch kein erfolg
die sitzen darum diese junge menschen
wollen nicht herumsitzen die wollen ihre
familien besuchen die wollen arbeiten
die wollen und die werden bleiben
realismus wir wollen eher reguläre
lebensgefährliche migration von denen
die dann in dieser lage enden weil sie
keinen schutz zugesprochen bekommen
die wollen wir reduzieren und dafür
wollen wir resettlement legale wege
aufnahme die wollen wir erhöhen
ja ich fand es waren einige interessante
punkte wo ich das auch schade fand dass
wir nicht weitergekommen sind aber ich
glaube das so vielleicht der
hauptunterschied ist dass bei euch
einfach viel mehr so ein politischer
dogmatismus ist einfach eine klare
haltung zu etwas und das bier mehr zum
politischen realismus dann auch
verpflichtet sind und geschaut haben was
ist politisch möglich was wir eigentlich
schade finden und was ich schade finde
ist dass über dieses thema und rassismus
überhaupt nach wie vor verhandelt werden
muss und diskutiert wird denn wir
glauben nach wie vor kein komponist das
ist die einzig richtige lösung bei
diesem thema ich habe sehr viel gelernt
das war eine gute diskussion aber ich
bin enttäuscht dass wir am ende bei den
themen wo er in der diskussion auch ein
konsens war da ich ja schon einiges da
ein kompromiss aber der fundamentale
unterschied ist wie erreichen wir das
und da bin ich überzeugt wie meine
kollegen und kolleginnen glaube ich wir
müssen menschen überzeugen
wir müssen mehrheiten überzeugen in
einigen eu-ländern wie man das erreichen
kann so dass diese mehrheiten
regierungen wählen die das dann auch tun
so gesagt gibt keine alternative dazu
dafür zu werben und dafür war dass eine
glaube ich gute diskussion weil doch am
ende bei recht viel gemeinsamkeiten
sichtbar wurden ich wünsche mir vor
allem dass die menschen die jetzt gerade
leiden die akut leiden die den tod
fürchten müssen nicht instrumentalisiert
werden für irgendein wahlkampf später
und ich hoffe dass die leute uns helfen
ehrlich gesagt dass mein letzter
hoffnung
ich danke euch für die diskussion damit
würde ich sie jetzt hier an dieser
stelle beenden das natürlich dass wir
hier sein kommen dann falls euch die
folge 13 fragen zum nachdenken angeregt
hat falls ihr euch gefallen hat last
gerne ein leichter hier könnt ihr gerne
den kanal abonnieren hier oben findet
ihr ein weiteres video von 13 fragen und
hier unten ein weiteres video zum thema